to judge someone by their past or not  their best that's how men judge women  yeah i mean that's that's common sense  the best predictor of future behavior is  past behavior if a dude cheated on every  single relationship he'd been in you  think he might cheat on me if a dude  picks bad boy bad boy bad boy bad boy  you're gonna think she might leave me  for a bad boy yeah i think yeah  definitely there is that risk of like  repetitive patterns of behavior  especially if you said someone hasn't  confronted their their trauma their past  trauma and then they're gonna repeat  into behaviors that they've had in the  past right but then i think i think  what's really great especially like with  covid that's happened is that like on  social media and it definitely there's  this uprising of people who are now  talking about past trauma healing mental  health